tá gravando tá gravando e aí galera que
assiste o meu canal
tudo bom com vocês
[ __ ] galera divisa velha sexta dia 10
de junho eu estou aí Campo Grande dia 11
de Junho eu estou aí Dourados dia 12 de
junho eu estou aí é o seguinte para não
demorar os próximos dois meses de show
vai aparecer aqui na tela por 5 segundos
e se a sociedade tivesse essa cidade que
a sua cidade tiver se a sua cidade [ __ ]
se a sua cidade estiver entre elas só
entra no site que vai aparecer embaixo
das datas ou clica no primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo que você vai comprar
o ingresso
esses dia eu parei para prestar atenção
na cor o cara sai da escola ele não quer
mais saber de escola não de vez em
quando bate uma saudade da escola Tinha
saudade de ir para escola minha mãe
acordar bem cedinho tem que estudar de
manhã que ô coisa que eu não entendo
porque é que o que a pessoa coloca
criança para estudar de manhã pode de
noite sabe tudo de manhã perde os
desenhos tudinho aí mamãe acordava
Pedrinho como é que o rica acorda ela
chega Senta do lado tá na hora de
acordar pra ir pra escola oh mãe tô com
tanto sono meu amor então faz assim
quanta Mamãe coloca a mesa pra gente
tomar café você dorme mais um pouquinho
tá Já já eu volto para te acordar como é
que a mãe do pobre acorda bora bora bora
bora bora pra escola
assistir filme ontem porque aqui é só
três vezes que ela disse embora vamos
embora vamos embora Se não for aí o
filho do rico levanta quer que ele tava
pisando pantufa tem que botar bantofa
num pezinho ele levanta na hora que o
cabo olha na camisa está aqui Joaquim 22
22 a camisa do candidato a vereador de
2001 e a cara do homem aqui ó e ele usa
para tudo para dormir para jogar bola
para lavar a louça é o filho do rico vai
tomar café tá lá a mesa cheia de [ __ ]
mamão melão presunto queijo tapioca
iogurte aí o Pobre vai tomar café tá lá
a mesa limpa limpa se passar um macaco
ele não mexe em nada aí lá na pontinha
mas bem na pontinha na Quina da mesa tem
quatro creme craque e um copinho com
três dedos de café é isso creme crack
com café e é se quiser aí o cara come
mancha a barriga cheia do colégio fica
olhando o lanche dos outros e o menino
do pobre ele pede só que ele não diz
assim ei me dá ele fica descrevendo que
a pessoa tá comendo até ela dar um
pedaço para ele tava comendo uma coxinha
e o cara fica assim ó tu é doido nisso
boa né [ __ ] assim na gordura bem
gostosinho tá do cabo desse jeito aí De
manhãzinha bem quentinho Tu é doido de
frango aí não o cara bota o o o coiso
doido como é o nome ketchup eu boto o
ketchup aí doido tu é doido o cara bota
fica bem gostoso não o cara bota na boca
vai de repente vai derretendo tem quando
vai derretendo nem mesmo não tem é doido
mas isso é bom demais amor eu lembro do
dia que eu comi isso aí na casa de um
primo meu que eu tava é meu primo a mãe
dele faz coxinha mas tu é doido mordendo
do jeito que tu tá mordendo aí tu é
doidona não isso é gostoso demais
vontade de comer o que eu faço só cara
não queria não mas eu vou comer né Aí
come eu fiz isso aí demais meu patrão e
briga na escola Engraçado é a discussão
e tu pegou meu adesivo grande não foi
Meu Eu eu foi não foi não foi não hum eu
eu acabei dizendo que não foi tu foi não
foi não foi eu não filha da [ __ ] bem
engraçado porque ele pula o i das
palavras armário é armário armário Bros
Mario Bros Rosário Rosário não foi eu
peguei isso aí não filha da [ __ ] tomou
no meio dessas coisas aqui não
eles chegam para perto do outro você
pensa que a pancada vai rolar eles fica
só assim ó
fica só rodando sem encostar um no outro
parece que a briga dele não é para
derrubar não é para ver quem tonta
primeiro aí tudo se aquieta todo mundo
cada um vai pro seu canto um pouco tá
ligado vira para trás e começa a
conversar sobre o assunto viu botei foi
medo hum medo tu não viu não viu não tem
amiguinho dele agora otário o rico já
tem uma pessoa que vai buscar ele no
colégio que o pai paga para ir buscar
ele no colégio se for em cidade pequena
é um mototáxi moto táxi paga por mês
11:30 ele tá na porta da escola para
pegar o menino e do pobre olha aqui ó ó
aí ó ó fica com as perninhas bem
boazinha pra você voltar pra casa não aí
eles vão para cá Só quente tudo
pequenininho segurando a bolsinha aqui e
eles vão em grupo e o grupo é a mesma
pessoa que brigaram na sala de aula meia
hora atrás o bom é isso ninguém guarda
recentemente só que o menino do pobre é
o seguinte ele volta para casa no sol
reclamando de tudo o sol quente 11:30
para meio-dia ah coitado morar uns 2 Km
de casa ele andando esses 2 Km no sol
suado cansado ele ainda arranja tempo e
disposição para tocar a campainha dos
sai correndo as meninas é o cão parece
que é uma mensagem do pobre para o rico
ai tu manda carrinho pegar o fim na
escola pô Vou tocar na tua campainha e
vou sair correndo falar da pus
geralmente é um grupinho de cinco e o
plano é tocar a campainha e todo mundo
sair correndo isso só pode não dá certo
por dois fatores primeiro fator se tiver
Cachorro e cachorro ele tem um Faro
especial para menino cachorro tem ódio
de menina Ah tá preparado aqui para
tocar a campanhando cara vai triscar o
dedo ai que desgraça aí o plano falha e
a número dois é o seguinte a gente para
antes de chegar na casa olha para todo
mundo e combina um toca e todo mundo
corre aí o cara vai lá tá todo mundo
preparado pensa que não toca na
campainha e sai correndo dá uns quatro
passa olha para trás tem um fela da [ __ ]
andando bem devagarzinho dizendo assim
você pega o taquei foi eu digo cara que
te dar um vazio já dá infância cara Teus
amigos te traindo né todo mundo corre
entra na primeira esquina que tem na
hora que acaba passa tu é doido nós
tinha combinado para todo mundo correr
rapaz você sabe que eu não gosto dessas
coisas esse negócio de ficar tocando
campanha e sai correndo cara sempre que
o cabra tinha combinado tinha aceitado
não gosta dessa qualquer filha da [ __ ]
eu falei agora movimento aí otário aí
vai os cara rodar de novo
rico chegando em casa vai logo correndo
para televisão do jeito que ele tá da
escola com o tênis e tudo ele sobe em
cima do sofá e fica assistindo lá em
casa se subir com tênis em cima do sofá
morre o pobre chegando em casa é
diferente ele vem todo animado
[Música]
olha para trás tá tudo só o barro que
ele trouxe dos pés e pede menino não
sujando aquilo ali ele fica uma tatuagem
olha pra direita a mãe Terminando de
limpar a cozinha o que é que acaba faz
aí voltando bem devagarzinho
[Música]
pega um pano
vai limpando com o pé e vai voltando
como se ele tivesse apagando a história
dele
[Música]
aí ele volta e finge que chegou de novo
é Mãe cheguei pode entrar para menina é
gênio na hora do almoço rico tem a maior
frescura para comer lasanha come meu
filho
tá bom tá bom vai assistir a Peppa vai
menino do pobre pode até dizer na hora
que ele não vai comer que pode estar
assistindo uma coisa importante um
Thundercats um Dragon Ball Naruto uma
Barbie umas três espiãs demais um clube
das Winx nunca se sabe você é importante
para criança agora tem uma frase que a
mãe fala que ela faz qualquer menino
sair de onde ele tiver isso vem comer eu
já vou mano eu tô assistindo aqui eu
guardar as panelas
aí você vê menino quebrando mato nos
peitos correndo Tu é doido mano se você
gostou desse vídeo você já sabe é só
clicar em gostei aqui no YouTube muita
gente assiste o vídeo já tá carregando
outro vídeo em outra aba aí na hora que
vai acabando Isso ele já fecha ele já
fecha e esquece de clicar em gostei
então clica aqui em gostei aqui embaixo
você vai me ajudar demais queria pedir
para você me seguir no Meu Snapchat que
é esse que tá aparecendo aqui na tela
tem uns personagens que eu só faço lá no
Snap eu quero que você veja então é isso
aí valeu e Girl
[Música]